night gathers and now my watch begins
it shall not end until my death I shall
take no wife hold no lands father no
children I shall wear no crowns and win
no glory I shall live and die my post I
am the sword in the darkness I am The
Watcher on the walls I am the shield
that guards the realms of men
I pledge my life and honor to the Nights
Watch for this night and all the nights
to come
legend tells of a winter that lasted a
generation and of a vast and terrible
darkness that fell across the land it
came to be known as the long night in
the midst of this darkness the White
Walkers emerged from the far north with
their armies of the Dead they waged war
against the living laying waste to
villages and old fasts leaving terror
and destruction in the wake after years
of brutal conflict and unbearable loss
an alliance of the first men and the
children of the forest managed to drive
the walkers and their minions back into
the frigid northern wastelands from
whence they came
to prevent another invasion the first
men erected the wall a massive
fortification 700 feet in height
stretching from the Frostfangs Mountains
in the West to the bay of seals in the
east it was a structure unlike any ever
built indeed some maintainer could only
been completed with the aid of giants or
using the powerful magic of the ancient
children of the forest
men were required to guard and maintain
it and thus the Nights Watch was born a
sworn Brotherhood tasked was defending
the realms of men against the dark
forces that lay beyond upon taking his
vows a brother of the Nights Watch
serves for life it is a life of hardship
and great sacrifice
so the oath was not be taken lightly the
punishment for desertion is death the
Nights Watch is divided into three vital
branches the Rangers the builders and
the stewards while all black brothers
are expected to take up steel should the
need arise the Rangers are the true
warriors of the watch centuries come and
gone and although the White Walkers have
yet to return another threat has emerged
barbarian tribes known as wildlings the
Rangers are charged with defending the
realm against these lawless savages the
builders are carpenters masons miners
and woodsmen tasked with maintaining the
wall as well as its various keeps towers
and structures which have fallen into
disrepair over the years the stewards
service cooks butchers and hunters they
tend to the horses and messenger Ravens
sew clothing gather firewood and bring
supplies up from the south the Nights
Watch is a diverse group proud
volunteers from noble houses stand
side-by-side with petty thieves
conscripted from dungeons plus
distinctions are left behind as our past
misdeeds a man gets what he earns on the
wall
and even a lowly as guttersnipe can rise
up in rank if he proves himself worthy
for thousands of years the Brothers of
the Nights Watch have stood there lonely
vigil as the seasons changed as brutal
wars raged in the south as dynasties
rose and fell the Nights Watch endured
we are the swords in the darkness we are
the Watchers on the wall we are the
shields that guard the realms of men